One, two, three, four.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(SINGING) I've been bruised and broken.
I've been torn in [MUTED] two.
I've been working and running.
Then, I have to run home to you.
And I'm not living in your life, and you're not living in mine.
We've been getting it wrong forever.
We'll get it right this time, and live in the high life.
[GUITAR RIFF]
Absolutely not-- absolutely not.
(SINGING) You're a thief.
You're a [MUTED] thief.
You're always getting caught.
I'm a b*tch, but I'm your b*tch, and I'm all you b*itches got.
And I'm not living in your life, and you're not living in mine.
We all get what we've been given,
but we're not going to give up trying.
To live in the high life.
Living in our high life.
We're up on the high life, and it's
a fine night to feel alive.
Living the high life.
Living in our high life.
We're up on the high life, and it's
a fine night to feel alive.
This song's a love song.
It's not an apology, but sometimes I
hate you reminding me of me.
(RAPPING) Woman, guess we're cut from the same cloth.
14 years in the same block.
Nine long months in your belly.
Down to the coombe and I still wasn't ready.
Three days late, I arrived at the party.
Smile on me face.
You're welcome, me hearty.
Back to the gaff in the liberties.
Christening party. up with the knees.
Girl, we are cut from the same cloth.
All you feel, I feel the same loss.
I see your eyes in the mirror.
Saint, angel, devil, sinner.
Still laughing at life with our fists up.
Still getting our tea down the chip shop.
Still tough, tongues sharp as a flick-knife.
Still here, still living the high life.
Woo!
(SINGING) And I'm not living in your life,
and you're not living in mine.
And this songs for all you mothers.
We're all going to be just fine.
[CHEERING]
We're living the high life.
Living in our high life.
We're up on the high life, and it's
a fine night to feel alive.
We're living the high life.
Living in our high life.
We're up on the high life.
And it's a fine night to feel alive.
Living the high life.
(SPOKEN) Living the high life.
Woo!
(SINGING) Living in our high life.
[LAUGHTER]
We're up on the high life.
(SPOKEN) Max.
The high life.
And it's a fine night to feel alive.
(SPOKEN) And it's a fine night to feel alive.
(SINGING) Living the high life.
Top of the world, Ma.
Ha, ha, ha.
Living in our high life.
We're up on the high life, and it's
a fine night to feel alive.
Living the high life.
[APPLAUSE]
We're up on the high life.
[CHEERING]